so we make way the full intro with the
Patriots wide receiver the pride of Kent
State Julian Edelman it's good to see
you listen you look good good to see you
too got the hard part going there
looking good slight parts like slight
part yeah I like her stuff down I heard
a guy seeding yeah your son carrying
Kieran yeah my boy can spin right huge
Pats fan yeah yeah yeah I heard he was a
little sad that I when I got hurt just
through the grapevine tell him I said
I'll be all right bub all right all
right this week well if we could get you
back on the field yeah get Deion luhan's
lewis some more touches he'd be thrilled
no no no fantasy it's his son is like 7
years of age and he he cried when you
got hurt he loves Dion Lewis it's not
Tom Brady or Gronk you know he likes the
little guys shorter guy quarter guy
sorry about that yeah how's the rehab
going here the rehabs going you know
it's as you know as a New England
Patriot we get better each day you go in
we try to work for improvement you find
out what you have to do to get it better
and work hard at it and you're gonna get
improvement and I've been attacking this
whole thing just like you know I attack
anything relentlessly just like the book
it's it's one of those things were it's
a new challenge on the plate you go
through a solid like I saw B you felt
sorry for yourself you don't feel sorry
for yourself but you ask questions why
this why that why this and then you you
you finally get into the mode where you
you get in the progression phase where
you started doing exercises and you
start doing things and you start seeing
that you could do put your socks on and
little things and those are like little
wins and you got a you're competing
against yourself every day so what do
people say to you outside of New England
like walking down the streets of New
York I just heard some guy say gee man
John Nichols Agee booed I was like hey
pads
wait so he g-men for he knew I was a
patriot yeah also he's let you know that
II used to Giants offense
yeah Giants okay yeah but but the reset
you're from California how do they treat
you when you're in California pretty
good
but it feels like people hate the
Patriots now outside of New England it's
a little different I don't know I feel
like there's Bostonians everywhere
though so like any time I go to a city I
just so happened to run into like the 30
Boston people that are visiting that
city or live in that city that
transplanted that city but would you
hate the Patriots if you didn't play for
the Patriots
no I actually used to like the Patriots
when I was in like eighth grade Tom
Brady won like his first Super Bowl and
everyone in my area kind of hated him
they're all about the Peyton Manning guy
and I always liked Tom Brady because he
was always the greedy underdog guy that
took the long road to get into where
he's at and had to earn everything he's
got so you know our stories are very
similar
did you tell Brady that story when how
long did it take before you told Brady
that story like four years four years I
mean it wasn't like I was uh did he
intimidate you
yeah terrified the first time I met him
it's in the book - yeah he walked in and
I had this by back then we didn't have
iPads we had you know the six inch
binder book and I had my playbook and
I'm running to like be five minutes
early for a meeting because you're
terrified of everything it's my first
day there and Brady walks in through the
doors and I like literally like almost
dropped my book and he goes hey Julian
or he goes hey Julian Tom here I go I
mean I've been seeing this guy since I
was on the asphalt of eighth grade in
high school but he knew your name
he knew my name he knew my name I think
my agents we have the same agents so
maybe that had something oh you think
Don you said hey you got a kid coming in
keep an eye out for his name's Julie
you'll never know Don Carter and Steve
they they do crazy things like that and
then they always have an eye out for me
so you go into this organization it's
all buttoned up you got Belichick who
could be intimidating you got Brady
who's the greatest quarterback of all
time then yeah you're looking around and
going oh my god there's Randy Moss and
Wes Welker yeah and you're a guy who was
a quarterback in high school and somehow
you're making this transition how'd you
keep it all sort of in perspective you
know it's kind of a mentality
I've been told the word know a lot in my
life you know whenever there was teams
and athleanrx get to OTAs you don't get
much you don't get many reps so you know
you got to take mental reps I would make
flashcards I'd be in the back pocket of
West well-core I'd be in shadows office
Scottie o our special teams coordinator
just to create value because that's what
you learn right when you get there you
see through the the veteran players of
like the Teddy brewskis the Kevin Fox
and all those guys that that I saw
earlier in my career you know it's the
more you can do around there and that's
how you embrace it do you think you had
you gone to another team yeah how do you
think your career would have played out
I don't know because it feels like you
go in there you have to you're going in
to a standard that's already set and a
lot of these teams organizations don't
have those high standards and you you
know in knowing what I know from how
your dad was with you to you know you
almost ate this up like all the auto
care put up another roadblock here I
don't what is it now I'm gonna find a
way to somehow get around it over
through it
it would be that could be applied to if
I was at another team as well I'd be
another roadblock so but the team
wouldn't have been any good though not
like the Patriots you know I'm just
happy I'm a patriot and you should be
I'm fortunate that uh
all the stars lined up for me to be
there so I don't
there's Belichick of a friend he's the
boss do you do you exchange Christmas
cards no I I mean I've seen Christmas
gift
I've seen him smiled twice
[Laughter]
no but there's a we have a picture of
him hugging you yeah that was the the
one time I saw one of the one time but
it looks like he's in tears there was I
don't think he was in tears yeah I think
he looks emotional have you ever seen
him cry no okay
you ever seen Brady crying aside from
this Super Bowl win and his mother of
course being there last year
I can either are you a better beer
drinker than Brady there is some old
talks about that there's a story out
there great he's pretty good
I got sources close to sources that he's
the chugging champ of the Patriots you
know he's pretty good yeah are you
better I'm pretty good too
you guys are so competitive you guys are
so competitive cannon is actually really
good too
oh yeah I think he could take us both
but I'm pretty sure Brady's not drinking
beer now though he's drinking like kale
shakes like he could get down drink like
ember ginger beer it's like that's no
fun that's no fun the book and I would
tell people just if if you're a parent
or you know you're you're having kids
and you're in you know getting them into
football or any sports the lessons you
got from your dad there's two ways to
look at it because as I'm looking at
some of the quotes in there dad's pretty
intimidating um and you could either
look at it as thank God you had him or
man he was really tough on you you know
it it goes back to when you're a kid you
look at your parents and you say what
why am I doing this they're so hard this
that but the older you get and once you
know I have a child now it's one of
those things where you look back on all
those those tough times and those things
and you say any was just trying to make
me better you know it's tough love and
my dad's kind of an old-school type of
guy you know he was really tough on me
but he was still always he still always
he cut me down but he'd always bring me
back up you know he'd always love me up
and and you know if you got a little too
hard on me you come in the room later
that night or something so you know
buddy you know I'm just trying to make
you better I love you to death I don't
want you to live the life I lived you
know my and that's the thing that amazes
me the most
is my dad didn't have a father and he's
like the most disciplined Dudley
do-right Saturday do his book work go
get a burrito do his business work after
that like the guy does is such a routine
Orion guy and he didn't have supervision
like I did like I don't understand how
it happened so my respect level as I get
older even gets higher for him just
because you know he's a self-made man
you know I I'm not necessarily a
self-made man because I had my dad's
direction and mentorship to help me get
to where I'm at now it's pretty cool
though just to see that that everybody
with their dad and the role that your
parents play in your life yeah or
whatever it's your mentor or whoever it
is I mean you know I'm sure he had I
mean some mentors but you know it's it's
pretty it's it makes you respect level
four that that guy who came up without a
father who got to where he's at or it
makes you fall in love with people's
stories and then that's what I liked
about I got some other I get some tough
questions for you can you stick around
yeah I can stick around right the book
is relentless you don't have anything
else going on do you you got other
appearances here I got a couple other I
got a couple other all right all right
hang around for a little hang around all
right yeah I got some really tough
questions for you he's Julian Edelman
the book is called relentless it's
available now is this gonna be a New
York Times bestseller I think we're
already on that list nice look at you
right number six are you higher than
Brady's health book I think he's got us
by a couple rounds he's got us by a
couple Wow but you know in the two Super
Bowls that I've won like I said there's
always been one motto you just got to
believe will grant be able to read this
book Julia yeah it's easy it's easy it's
easy there's there's not enough pictures
in there for drunk drunk is actually
Sivan I've got on racist savant the dude
if you say Gronk what's 32 times a
hundred and fifty thousand throw the
number out you can throw the number out
any time it's numbers drunks yeah Paulie
but you have to use beers that didn't
have ever since thirty two beers times a
thousand beers and he could didn't do it
something like that beers or chicks 18
after the hour will continue with Julian
Edelman once again the book
relentless we're back right after this
in the Dan Patrick show the buck is
relentless he's Julian Edelman who is
rehabbing won't be playing the rest of
this season I did ask you this let me
ask you at least on the record if you
knew the Patriots were gonna be in the
Super Bowl could you be healthy enough
to play
in that game it would be tough you'd be
cutting it real close you know it's one
give me a percentage of where you think
you would be be it's the first week in
February February so we got November
December and January yeah that's that's
like Jerry Rice time and the last time
someone did that they broke their
patella so so it's not worth the risk I
don't know if it's worth the risk
you know it'd be uh it's not it's not
that it's not worth the risk I just
don't think I would be ready as far as
strengthening your leg like there's one
thing for you to be good enough to go
and play but then there's one thing to
be good enough to go play at a high
level and I don't know if I would be you
know I'd be putting myself at risk of
getting hurt because of the compensation
of my right leg not probably being a
strong enough as my left or anything
like that so it would be a tough tough
kind of thing to think about when did
you hear about Jimmy Garoppolo being
traded I was actually on a text chain
with him through some marketing people
when he found out yeah and I'm sitting
there and I'm watching the TV I'm
sitting here like this guy pearl would
he Jimmy straited he can't go to this
thing tomorrow well so you're gonna go
to an event yeah and so that's how I
found out I was like wow this is I'm
sitting there kind of like well Jimmy's
gone so that's crazy surprised you know
nothing surprises me anymore what tell
me what you saw in practice because we
only saw a small sample size how how
great can he be I mean the kids has an
opportunity to be good you know that's
that's for sure I mean he showed it in
in the games that he's played he's got
that kind of calm little cool like
gunslinger mentality and in there kind
of like one of the boys you know it's
it's gonna be fun to watch his
progression you know I mean he's still
he's gonna have some learning pains up
there but uh you know I think he'll be
good
all right serious question and try to be
objection you know if you if you can
more handsome drop lower Brady you know
I've had this conversation before
Jimmy's like with Brady you had this
conversation okay all right my been
Jimmy's like like the young stallion
like hot kind of guy yeah Brady's like
the old man sippin on a whiskey with
like a nice suit on Nance um mm-hmm so I
mean it's it's a toss-up I there's no
wrong answer here's what you're saying
yeah moreover yeah it's it's it's it's a
split I'm more of a Dola guy I think
Amendola better-looking than both Wow
Wow there's your headline that's that
the first take their birthdays birthday
happy birthday Dola how old is he we
don't we don't talk ages in football
well you're 31 like once you get past 30
then you don't do birthdays you don't do
birthday oh okay I'm only two so would
you lie about your age if you would this
is what I tell like so we have like all
the people that are from upper division
that player personnel Scouts and and
they always come in and these are the
guys that like put the amount of
injuries you have with your age with the
position you play and like Bill's got
like a whole like stat guy team no does
this so I go in and there's this guy
Richard and I always talk to him and I
say when I was 11 years old or when I
was 14 years old I I wasn't growing so
like my parents were worried so I
wouldn't saw a doctor and did all these
tests and everything they're like well
he's only has the bones an 11 year old
so I always tell them I'm 31 but I'm
really only 28
your bones are over 28 years old I
brought this up to you before I didn't
think you were forthcoming and I
understand why not the hit that you took
against Seattle in the Super Bowl is one
of the hard I was on the field so I got
to hear it I don't know how you stayed
up I don't know how you weren't
concussed at least bell rung but you
said you weren't yeah were you concussed
no like how do you if you if you really
want to know if a guy's kind of dinged
up yeah you know like usually you'll
drop ball and hands will go up like
those are those are the when you see a
guy do that he's messed up but
Chancellor is a big dude yeah and hits
you right on right that'll be good
yeah it was a good hit did you say
anything to him you know what in that
game we were talking I was trying to
talk a little bit with some of the guys
and he's such a polite competitor who
wants to take your head off
yeah like well you wanted to talk trash
well I would be like you know I remember
the first play I went and tried to Jack
him up like one of the first run plays
and he like let me up and got me and he
goes I don't know but it was something
along those lines I'm like I can't even
talk to this guy like he's too polite
like and it's fun to compete against
guys like that okay but a bigger play
the catch against the Falcons or that
catch and holding on to it against
Seattle those are two of the Great's in
Super Bowl history yeah I mean the
Falcons one was pretty I think that was
a better catch just for the simple fact
that it could have been really really
bad if we didn't get hit that cuz you
know it's cover five two men two guys
are converging into the ball the DB had
his eyes on the ball before you and
that's like a nightmare and then when
the ball is tipped up in the air with
two guys coming and hard you know for
the most part I just didn't want the
ball get picked cuz that's a game and
you know once I saw it came off a leg I
just tried to keep my eye on the ball so
I would say that that one was probably a
little crazier because there's more time
in the other one but you're yet you're
saying I caught it I caught it yeah yeah
I was because it didn't seem like they
were gonna believe you
and all of a sudden you everybody looked
at it and saw lit up on the the replayed
Jumbotron it's like I'll be damned he
caught it yeah it was you never know
what to catch these days but did you
complete the process
yeah that's nonsense yeah I feel bad for
my guy with the knee or the leg that
dislocate indeed they give him a
touchdown in Chicago Zack Miller yeah
you
there was terror the tug oh they didn't
give it a touchdown they took it away
from me I don't know your best Gronk
story like the one that you're gonna
tell your kids that you can tell your
kids best wrong story there's like the
first time we ever went out in Boston
and this guy is choosing your words
carefully yeah I love it very we go out
and he's a rookie and this guy you know
is just dancing with his shirt off
pouring liquids on him and himself and
people are looking at this guy like who
the hell is this guy what is this guy
doing I go don't you wait this guy's
gonna be an absolute monster but that's
probably the most that's that's the one
I can share it was absolutely I mean
people didn't know who he was and now
you go out with Gronk it's it's a man
you go out with Gronk no you can you
really can't I mean he's a rockstar a
rockstar plus he embraces it it's it's
it's sort of you know Jordan didn't want
you to see him out like Brady wouldn't
want to have you see him out grant
doesn't dronkers like Barkley Barkley
doesn't care yeah he did Krunk doesn't
go go out as much as what people think
oh yeah you know it's just the one time
he goes out it's a huge thing so I don't
know is there is there anything you do
or did as a quarterback better than
Brady does aside from running beside
from run could you beat Brady in a race
have you went backwards and he went
forward probably a night so I thought um
I had a good cadence give it give it let
me hear I had it like wait 20 check
check check check check like I could
always hit guys to jump off Brady he's
pretty good at it he's good too but I
think I may have him on a cake Brady's
got a little higher pitch though too
much he gets mad at me he's sensitive
you see nice he's soft yeah that's all
right
he needs some mint
I tear my ACL so I tear my ACL right and
and the first thing he says did me like
a week after he goes take a tablespoon
of cement bubs we'll see you buddy the
book is relentless and what stood out is
how honest you are with your
relationship with your father I would
tell people just to pick up the book for
that because it was very revealing
enlightening and I and I appreciated you
letting us in sort of what it's like to
be an underdog because people don't look
at you as an underdog anymore yeah not
anymore not anymore thirty-one with the
bones of a 28 year old they don't look
you as an underdog an unbelievable
mustache what's a beard well you know
there's more flavor here is that what it
is how are you is the father are you uh
he's doing great
how's the bay you've changed diapers I
change diapers you front-to-back with
the females
I love that's good you know we just did
the pumpkin patch the aquarium we're
gonna have Thanksgiving in the Bay Area
with the folks that'll be awesome it's
fun the older they get it's it gets
better and better each time because you
start to see more of your family in them
and don't miss out on these things now I
know it'll break your heart it's because
I missed out a lot with my four kids
because I work second shift you never
get it back yeah and it may seem like
she's not gonna remember she'll remember
yeah and you'll remember and that's the
king yeah Congrats on the book it's
great to see you
you were great a lot of fun thanks dad
we appreciate that by the way I like
when Julian comes in and goes hey I'll
admit it and I watched the show
occasionally like like he wasn't allowed
to admit it because he's a member of the
Patriots yeah my jumper is pretty good
yeah thank you
splash Rich Eisen is gonna join us
coming up the book again is relentless
it's not as good as Tom Brady's book
apparently at least not yet but it's
getting there yeah it's definitely no
it's no here's you know for a while
Brady here's your coming he smells it Oh
was it for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]